y
[Música]
el ecuador está en estado de excepción
ante la inseguridad del presidente
guillermo lasso aseguró que la medida es
necesaria para hacer frente a la
violencia causada por el narcotráfico la
orden además blinda legalmente a
policías y militares
crece el temor por un eventual pone exit
del primer ministro polaco advirtió que
la unión europea debe respetar su
soberanía a lo que bruselas respondió
anunciando castigos financieros la
atención llega luego de que un tribunal
constitucional polaco dictaminó que
algunos tratados de bloques son
incompatibles con la ley nacional
hoy es el día internacional de la lucha
contra el cáncer de mama una jornada
para sensibilizar sobre la importancia
de realizarse un examen regularmente con
la finalidad de detectar cualquier signo
o anomalía en esta emisión les mostramos
como el deporte es un método eficaz para
combatirlo
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 sierra blanco como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos
en el ecuador donde el presidente
guillermo lasso decretó el estado de
excepción ante un aumento de los índices
de violencia a causa del narcotráfico
ordenando así la movilización en las
calles de policías y militares además
los blinda legalmente veamos el informe
de alva santana
estado de expresión en todo ecuador tras
la muerte de un niño de 11 años por un
fuego cruzado entre la policía y un
ladrón el problema de la inseguridad ha
pasado a ser una urgencia para el
ejecutivo de guillermo lasso todos los
sectores sociales y políticos debemos
trabajar en absoluta unidad porque en
las calles del ecuador hay un solo
enemigo el
narcotráfico más del 70% de las muertes
violentas que hoy ocurren en la
provincia del guayas está de alguna
forma relacionada con el tráfico de
drogas con esta medida de urgencia
aplicada en todo el país se espera que
la policía y el ejército tengan más
libertad de acción para controlar el
repunte del crimen organizado además el
gobierno prometió blindar a las fuerzas
de la seguridad con indultos y respaldo
absoluto de su parte ante eventuales
acusaciones injustas algo que ha
preocupado a las organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos ya la
defensoría del pueblo
este gobierno
indultará a todos aquellos que hayan
sido
injustamente condenados por haber
cumplido con su labor el ejecutivo
enviará en los próximos días un nuevo
proyecto de ley dedicado exclusivamente
a respaldar a nuestros agentes del orden
este estado de excepción con ver que con
el aplicado hace tres semanas en las
cárceles de ecuador tras el motín
carcelario más violento del país que
dejó al menos 118 muertos y decenas de
familias afectadas en guayaquil
actualmente la presidencia de guillermo
lasso enfrenta un cúmulo de adversidades
con su implicación en los pandora papers
y la disputa con la asamblea nacional
para que se aprueben sus reformas
económicas de corte neoliberal en otras
noticias el ex presidente de eeuu donald
trump presentó una demanda para mantener
en secreto los registros de la casa
blanca sobre la toma del capitolio por
parte de sus seguidores el pasado 6 de
enero esto es visto como una escalada en
sus esfuerzos para obsta utilizar al
comité del senado que los investiga por
este ataque que dejó al menos seis
muertos nuestro corresponsal en
washington dice cristóbal vázquez nos
explicó que argumentan zombies y
soldados en su demanda veamos
si con esta demanda trump y su defensa
sus abogados pues se buscan que los
archivos nacionales y que el comité de
la cámara de representantes pues no
acceda a las conversaciones ya los
documentos y a las reuniones que tono
rompe el ex presidente tuvo antes del 6
de enero día que se ocurrió la toma al
capitolio del otro para argumentar que
tiene fuero presidencial para que los
archivos nacionales nos revelen esta
información y no accedan a esta
información los miembros del comité de
la cámara de representantes sin embargo
ya la casa blanca se ha pronunciado y le
ha dicho a los archivos nacionales que
pues tiene toda la potestad de revelar
esta información al congreso y a las
personas que lo requieran porque pues es
finalmente el presidente en funciones es
decir yo bailé en el que decide cuáles
son los límites del fuero presidencial
al que apela donald trump para que estos
documentos y esta información sobre sus
reuniones antes del 6 de enero no se
conozcan
en medio de las tensiones entre la unión
europea y polonia el primer ministro
polaco mateusz maravilla que insistió en
el derecho nacional que prima sobre el
europeo las declaraciones las ofreció
ante el pleno de la eurocámara que hoy
debate la crisis creada tras la reciente
sentencia del tribunal constitucional
polaco que cuestiona la primacía del
derecho comunitario sobre el doméstico
ante esto la presidenta de la comisión
europea dulzura von der layen aseguró
que se tomarán medidas económicas contra
polonia por socavar la independencia
judicial que según ella es algo que la
unión europea no puede arriesgar
creemos hombre está que las reglas del
juego deben ser las mismas para todos y
aceptar las debe ser un valor compartido
para las instituciones que crearon los
tratados no tiempo la que aprobó son 2
este es el estado de derecho es
inaceptable ver una expansión de poderes
como un hecho dado no es posible imponer
su voluntad sino una base legal es
inaceptable que la financiación se
utilice como chantaje para hablar de
sanciones o incluso de otras amenazas
que van demasiado lejos y que a menudo
escuchamos de otros estados miembros
héctor expansión cosas
o no de members
y que no tiene rival noche al lado
señorías no podemos ni permitiremos que
se pongan en peligro nuestros valores
comunes
andy options o no la comisión actuará y
todas las opciones son conocidas la
primera opción son las infracciones en
las que impugnamos legalmente la
sentencia del tribunal constitucional
polaco en adopción
este condicional y sin la conexión al
adha financials otra opción es el
mecanismo de condicionalidad y otras
herramientas financieras el gobierno
polaco tiene que explicarnos cómo
pretende proteger el dinero europeo dada
esa sentencia de su tribunal
constitucional after constitucional
watch
precisamente nuestra corresponsal en
bruselas de esther herrera nos contó más
de lo sucedido hoy en el debate de la
eurocámara
buenos días como comentaba es un debate
muy tenso hoy en la eurocámara en que el
primer ministro polaco mateos morawiecki
ha asegurado que la unión europea está
chantajeando al país por las
advertencias de la unión europea
precisamente la presenta la comisión
europea aus la font der leyen ha sido
muy dura en que ha recordado que es
capaz de congelar los fondos europeos al
país estamos hablando de que están en
juego 200 mil millones de euros
aproximadamente incluidos los fondos
europeos
postpandemia pero el primer ministro
polaco ha insistido en un tono muy duro
que defenderá a defenderá a las últimas
consecuencias la constitución polaca que
está por encima del derecho europeo y ha
negado que polonia quiera salir de la
unión europea aún así ha ido más allá ha
criticado que la justicia europea esté
llevando a cabo una revolución
silenciosa para limitar la soberanía de
los países porque según moore había
hecho y la justicia europea no debe
entrometerse
en cuestiones en que no tiene
competencias sin embargo lo cierto es
que todos los estados miembros cuando
entran dentro de la unión europea asumen
que el derecho europeo está por encima
del nacional y eso es justamente lo que
quiere dinamitar a polonia este
desencuentro es uno más ha habido muchas
tensiones en los últimos años entre
varsovia y bruselas y no hay visos de
que realmente pueda haber una solución
pronto
continuamos en europa en españa el
volcán cumbre vieja cumple un mes de
erupción la lava ha acabado con miles de
edificaciones y ha obligado a evacuar a
cerca de siete mil personas además se
calcula que los daños suman un valor de
201 millones de euros unos daños que el
gobierno pretende subsanar con un plan
de recuperación anunciado en los últimos
días nos amplía manuel la canal
la palma cumple un mes de la hoy se
misas el volcán cumbre vieja inició un
proceso eruptivo fuerte el 19 de
septiembre ese mismo día y por el plan
de emergencias volcánicas de canarias se
decretó el estado de emergencia
el presidente español llegó a la palma
un día después de su erupción cuando la
lava del volcán ya acaba con las
primeras edificaciones quiero trasladar
el compromiso total el compromiso
rotundo de que esté esta erupción no va
a hacer que haya gente que se quede
atrás que se quede dañada desde el punto
de vista económico diez días después la
lava del volcán llegó al mar provocando
un miedo por las consecuencias en el
ecosistema marino y también
desprendiendo unos gases sumamente
tóxicos afectando la calidad del aire de
ciertas partes de la isla
las cifras dan cuenta de la magnitud de
la erupción volcánica hasta el momento
ha destruido cerca de 1800 edificaciones
y ha obligado a 7000 personas a
abandonar sus hogares
además ha cubierto
754 hectáreas de tierra gran parte de
ellas dedicadas al cultivo también ha
acabado con cerca de 60 kilómetros de
carreteras se calcula que los daños
suman una cifra de 200 un millón de
euros sin embargo a un mes de erupción
no ha cobrado la vida de ninguna persona
el gobierno se ha comprometido a
entregar un plan de reconstrucción y hoy
aprobamos en un tiempo récord el primer
real decreto-ley el segundo perdón real
decreto-ley en relación con ayudas a los
afectados por un importe global de
214 millones de euros el volcán entró en
una fase de estabilidad y lentitud sin
embargo autoridades de la palma han
afirmado que no tiene perspectiva de
mainar
corea del norte realizó un nuevo
lanzamiento de misiles al menos dos de
corto alcance que terminaron en el mar
de japón la nueva prueba aumenta las
tensiones con la vecina cuidad del sur
alva santana nos trae todos los detalles
otra prueba de misiles de corea del
norte la quinta desde el 11 de
septiembre con dos misiles balísticos
que terminaron en el mar de japón
idear y el lanzamiento de misiles por
parte de corea del norte es una
violación de las resoluciones del
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
y condenó enérgicamente la acción acabo
de reunirme con el consejo de seguridad
nacional donde hemos recogido
información sobre los misiles y hemos
discutido nuevas medidas
las primeras investigaciones indican que
al menos uno de los misiles eso es el bm
de corto alcance un tipo de arma que el
gobierno norcoreano lleva tiempo
probando
y exchange y la situación actual en la
península se encuentra en un punto
crítico y todas las partes implicadas
deben centrarse en la situación general
actuar con moderación comprometerse a
mantener la paz y la estabilidad en la
península y seguir en la dirección
correcta del diálogo y la consulta el
régimen de corea del norte ha apostado
tradicionalmente por una fuerte
militarización con un programa nuclear
muy polémico en una marcha reciente del
ejército el país asiático presumió de la
cantidad de armas desarrolladas en los
últimos cinco años entre ellas lo que si
sospecha es un misil hipersónico
mientras desde eeuu siguen abiertos a
retomar las conversaciones diplomáticas
sobre el plan nuclear de corea del norte
estancadas desde 2019
y hoy martes 19 de octubre es el día
internacional de la lucha contra el
cáncer de mama el cáncer más frecuente
entre las mujeres una de cada dos se
tiene el riesgo de desarrollar esta
enfermedad a lo largo de su vida un
método no tan conocido pero muy eficaz
para poder combatirlo es la práctica
deportiva está comprobado
científicamente que reduce significa
significativamente el riesgo de
recurrencia mejora la supervivencia y
también ayuda a restaurar la confianza
un centro de lyon en francia propone
cursos de esgrima para las mujeres que
están luchando contra esta enfermedad
con la punta de sus espadas estas
mujeres combaten a un enemigo común el
cáncer de mama algunas se encuentran en
remisión y otras están atravesando la
quimioterapia como natalie quien fue
diagnosticada en marzo pasado
donde las protecciones la esgrima es una
buena actividad para desahogarse y
descargarse a menudo asociamos al
enemigo invisible frente a nuestra
espada con el cáncer con nuestras
espadas lo perseguimos lo matamos y lo
destruimos en millones de pedazos al
expulsión y no su la mayoría de las
participantes conservan importantes
secuelas de sus operaciones la esgrima
les ayuda a recuperar la fuerza en los
brazos especialmente junto a sus
cicatrices
[Música]
para no trabajar a este fin la
entrenadora ha sido especialmente
formada para esta terapia post cáncer
trabajamos en el lado que fue operado
eso significa que una mujer que es
diestra y fue operada en su lado
izquierdo debe trabajar en su lado
izquierdo si ella fue operada en ambos
lados debe trabajar en ambos lados
trabajamos sobre todo en gestos hacia
arriba lo que les permite elevar un poco
más el brazo y recuperar la movilidad
vieron por la cirugía numerosos estudios
científicos se prueban que la actividad
física regular permite disminuir el
riesgo de recurrencia del cáncer de mama
en un 25% y de mejorar las tasas de
supervivencia en un 30% martín ha sido
diagnosticada dos veces en 2007 y 2019
desde que empezó a practicar esgrima ha
constatado mejoras importantes en su
salud
recupere el movimiento de mi brazo
derecho gracias a los ejercicios que
hacemos llegamos a las clases cansadas y
nos vamos llenas de energía una práctica
para luchar contra la enfermedad pero
también para devolver a estas mujeres en
la moral y el deseo de luchar
de esta manera llegamos al final de la
informativa en france24 continuar con
nosotros hay mucho más para ver nuestro
canal feliz día
[Música]